due to a combination of savvy marketing
a powerful international draw and not
taking itself too seriously
the fast and furious franchise has
become a veritable money printing
machine
but not everyone wants to be a part of
it here are some actors who turned down
roles
in the fast saga denzel washington would
have been
a massive get for the fast and furious
franchise the series has boasted its
fair share of big time actors but denzel
is on another level not only has he been
incredibly successful at the box office
but he's also taken home two oscars for
his roles in glory and
training day yeah i know you got secrets
everybody got secrets
you know you like to get wet though
deadline writes that universal
approached denzel to appear at the end
of the sixth film
which would segue into him playing the
role of the main villain in furious 7.
he apparently was not interested however
and turned down the opportunity
ultimately the role went to jason
statham statham is obviously a big star
in his own right but not quite on the
same level as the two-time oscar winner
you may be unfamiliar with the name
deepika padukone
unless you're a big fan of bollywood
however the model actress is hugely
popular in indian cinema and that makes
her a star in the largest film producing
industry in the world
the fast and furious franchise owes much
of its success to the international
market
so it makes sense that they'd want to
recruit worldwide stars into the fold
they tried to do just that with paducone
and furious 7 but she had to turn down
the offer
at the time paducone had never appeared
in an american film
as she told india today she had already
committed to a domestic film and didn't
feel right backing out but she also said
she would
love to do a hollywood film in the
future she got her wish just a few years
later
and in a role alongside vin diesel as
well paducone appeared in
xxx return of xander cage in 2017 and
has reportedly been cast in
xxx4 when the fast and furious franchise
began
in 2001 jaw rule was one of the biggest
rappers in the world
he was in the process of making the
transition to acting and appeared in a
very small role in the fast and the
furious as
a character named edwin who went up
against paul walker and ven diesel's
characters in a street race
he did not win
interestingly ja rule could have gone on
to be one of the faces of the franchise
if he'd been
interested in an interview with grant
land john singleton the director of too
fast
too furious recalled jaw got too big for
himself he turned it down he turned down
a half a million dollars to be in the
sequel singleton said he repeatedly
tried to get jaw rolled to the table but
eventually decided to swap his character
out for one played by a different rapper
ludacris who has since appeared in more
than half of the fast and furious films
apparently ludacris wasn't the first
potential replacement for jaw rule
originally rapper redman was eyed to
take on the role
once jaw rule dropped out of too fast
too furious redman was apparently geared
up to replace him he apparently had to
drop out due to scheduling conflicts the
tv series method and red came out around
the same time
as did a few other projects instead the
role went to ludicrous
just like ja rule redman's acting career
has been fairly stagnant
since this role passed him by it would
have been interesting to see how the
franchise might have evolved if either
one of them had been cast instead of
ludicrous
even though the fast and furious
franchise has become a blockbuster
series over the years it took a few
films for it to find its footing and
figure out what it wanted to be
most of the main players have stuck with
it over the long haul but the core group
didn't come together overnight
in fact in 2017 a producer revealed that
timothy oliphant
was initially targeted to star in the
first film apparently when the fast and
the furious was originally pitched to
universal the studio agreed to produce
the film
as long as oliphant was cast as the lead
role of don tireto
oliphant turned the role down which
brought the filmmakers to their backup
vin diesel diesel took the reins of the
franchise and has appeared in almost
every film
since the fast and furious franchise
sure loves its european baddies
in recent films we've seen luke evans
jason statham and
idris elba all show up as central
antagonists
an impressive roster that also almost
included david tennant
yes we reportedly almost saw the
one-time doctor who
tangling with vin diesel and dwayne
johnson so what went wrong
well i don't know i can't worry about
everything according to latino review
tenant was in talks with director justin
lin about taking on a major role in fast
and furious six
we don't know which part he was being
considered for but it seems likely that
it would have been one of these shaw
brothers
roles that eventually went to evans and
statham whatever ultimately went down
during negotiations tenant wound up
moving on to other projects
tennant has proven he can do
over-the-top villainy very well
his performance in jessica jones as the
despicable kilgrave gave audiences one
of the best marvel villains to date
we certainly wouldn't mind seeing him
get behind the wheel in the fast and
furious franchise
another rapper who was targeted for the
franchise but had to turn it down
eminem was actually approached twice to
be a part of the fast and furious films
both times prior commitments kept him
from coming on board
and both roles he turned down would go
on to be major parts in the films
eminem was actually offered a very big
role in the first film he was approached
to take on the role of brian o'connor
which eventually went to paul walker
when eminem was approached to take the
role he was currently in development of
his own film eight mile
and had to remain available for it just
think eminem could have been one of the
faces of the franchise
according to fuse eminem was later
approached to do a song for the
soundtrack of furious 7.
he again turned it down due to a
different film he was already heavily
involved with the movie southpaw and he
did not want to have multiple songs
competing with one another
eliza deshku was extremely in demand
when the fast and the furious was in
development
apparently the role of mia toretto was
not only offered to deshku but was
reportedly written specifically with her
in mind
deshku turned the role down for unknown
reasons but she was extremely busy at
the time with both television and film
projects
so it isn't hard to imagine why many
different stars were reportedly attached
after dushku passed
jessica biel kirsten dunst sarah
michelle geller bijou phillips and
natalie portman are all rumored to have
auditioned for the role before it went
to jordana brewster
vin diesel returned to the franchise
fold later but he did refuse an offer to
appear in too fast too furious and the
reason is fascinating
diesel was offered 25 million dollars to
star in too fast too furious but didn't
like the script or the direction the
series was headed
he viewed the first film as a classic
and said
i was an idealist and to me the script
wasn't continuing the story
they were capitalizing on the brand and
milking the success of it as long as
they could
of course since diesel's full-time
return to the franchise with the fourth
installment
the fast and furious movies have morphed
from a story about cops out to
infiltrate a street racing gang
into a wildly over-the-top saga fueled
by globetrotting action espionage and an
increasingly casual relationship with
the laws of nature
you're ready the ground's coming fast
continuing the story will only take you
so far
this one is a bit of a cheat because as
far as we can tell
guardians of the galaxy star dave
bautista has never actually been offered
a role in the franchise
that said his refusal of a fan pitch was
enough of an adamant refusal that we had
to include it
once the news broke that john cena would
be appearing in f9 a fan tagged batista
on twitter with this pitch
the rock and john cena will get a fast
and furious spin-off also
and dave bautista will be the villain
batista responded with two nauseated
emojis and the words
thank you for your consideration hashtag
i'd rather do
good films now we love batista but
that's a pretty bold response from a man
who has starred in not one but
two escape plan sequels besides those
two missteps however batista has been
fairly choosy with most of his roles
never say never but that big time dunk
on vin diesel's franchise will probably
keep the animal
out of fast and furious films for a
while check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about the
fast saga are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one